Now that you have a better Idea of what data
science is, and what data scientist do, let's talk about
how data science can be applied across a wide spectrum
of industries. You might have signed up for this class under
the notion that if you become a data scientist, you'll
end up working for a Silicon Valley startup. Well it's true
that most tech companies do employ data scientists. Data science
can also be used to solve problems in many different fields.
What are some examples of the types of
problems being solved using data science? Well for one,
Netflix uses collaborative filtering algorithms to recommend movies
to users based on things they've previously watched. Also,
elements of many popular social media websites are
powered by data science. Things like recommending new connections
on Linkedin, constructing your Facebook news feed or
suggesting new people to follow on Twitter. Many other
online services or apps such as dating websites like
OKCupid or right sharing services like Uber using the
vast amount of user data available to them, not
only need to customize and improve the user experience but
also to publish interesting anthropological findings regarding people's behavior
in the offline world on their blogs. Okay, so
I know what you're thinking. So far, all of
these seem like problems data scientists are expected to solve,
but data scientists work in many domains. Data
science concepts are integral in processing and modeling data
in the field bioinformatics where scientists are working on
projects like annotating genomes and analyzing data sequences. This
past summer, data science for social good fellows
in Chicago worked on a project attempting to solve
Chicago's bus crowding issues using data. In addition, physicists
use data science concepts when building a 100 terabyte
database of astronomical data collected by the Sloan
digital sky server. This one's cool. Analyzing electronic
medical records allowed the city of Camden, New
Jersey to save enormous amounts of money by targeting
their efforts towards specific buildings accounting for a
majority of emergency admission. Finally, NBA teams like the
Toronto Raptors are installing a new technology, sports
view cameras, on the basketball courts. They collect huge
amounts of data on players movement and playing styles.
This helps teams to better analyze game trends and improve
coaching decisions. You've probably noticed by now that data science
is making an impact in areas far and wide. Data
science isn't simply a trendy new way to think about
tech problems. It's a tool that can be used to
solve problems in a variety of fields. Data scientists are
working at Silicon Valley start-ups to enrich our online experiences,
but they're also doing important work in our
cities, in our laboratories and in our sports stadiums.